[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان ما نشهده من الحكومه الايرانيه
ونظام في طهران هو رغبتهما في القاء اللوم
على دول اخرى بسبب التابعات الناجمه عن
سوء معاملتهم للشعب الايراني النساء في
ايران اللواتي يقفن في وجه سوء العاملته
يتظاهرن ضد الحكومه قمنا بذلك لانهن
اكتفينا من الحكومه الايرانيه وبدلا من
معالجته همومهن والاصغاء اليهم ايران
وتحاول التنصل من سلوكياتها واللقاء اليوم
على دول اخرى من ضمنها بريطانيا غير انه
كل ما يجري الان هو نتيجه لسلوكيات
الحكومه الايرانيه ونحن بدورنا سنضمن
المحافظه على امن الشعب البريطاني وكل من
يعيش ويعمل في المملكه المتحده وسنصلت
الضوء على شجاعه المراه الايرانيه التي
وقفت وعبرت بصوتها وطالب بالتغيير في
ايران
[موسيقى]
بصفه وزيرا للخارجيه اصدرت استدعاء للقائم
بالاعمال الايرانيه والواقع هو ان احد
المسؤولين في وزارتي هو الذي تحدث معه
واوضح له ان بريطانيا تاخذ اي تهديدات او
حتى تهديدات المحتمله من اي حكومه اجنبيه
لكل من يسكن بريطانيا على محمل الجد كما
اوضحنا في شكل جديد باننا دائما سنحمي
الشعب البريطاني وكل من يسكن على اراضينا
والرساله التي اود ان ابعث بها الى
القياده الايرانيه هي وصول الشعبكم يصرخ
مطالبا بالتغيير وما نقوله للايرانيين هو
ان هذا التحدي هو التحديهم وهذه المسؤوليه
مسؤوليتهم وعلى النظام الاصغاء لشعبه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]